bon jeu
aujourd'hui on va parler de rené guénon
le nom de rené guénon vous dit peut-être
quelque chose
c'est un auteur dont on entend beaucoup
parler depuis les années 2000 alors même
qu'il est mort en 1951
et quand je dis qu'on en entend beaucoup
parler je parle du grand public et non
pas des milieux universitaires
rené guénon et très peu étudiée en fac
de philosophie malgré l' influence qu'il
a exercée sur le monde intellectuel au
20e siècle
et l'une des raisons pour lesquelles on
parle beaucoup de rené guénon
c'est parce que c'est un intellectuel
qui a prédit la fin du monde
alors dit comme ça ça peut paraître un
peu loufoques voire même un peu
grotesque
qu'est ce que c'est que ces
intellectuels qui parle de fin du monde
ça fait pas très sérieux
et voir qu'on n'a pas affaire ici un
vulgaire gourou de secte
on n'a pas affaire à un illuminé qui
prétendrait avoir reçu un message des
anges
on a affaire à quelqu'un qui s'est
attaché tout au long de sa vie
à étudier les doctrine spirituelle
orientale
pas seulement orientale d'ailleurs mais
surtout orientale et qui considère qu'il
ya dans ces doctrines des enseignements
que nous autres occidentaux modernes
avons perdu
le combat de rené guénon fut un combat
pour la réhabilitation
et la réactivation des sagesse
ancestrale de l'humanité
et on va voir aujourd'hui à quoi a
conduit selon lui la perte de ces
sagesse ancestrale
à quoi conduit l'éloignement de
l'occident vis-à-vis de la spiritualité
un éloignement qui serait la source est
le symptôme de l'effondrement prochain
de notre civilisation
donc je le disais à l'instant rené
guénon est mort en 1951
c'est donc un homme qui a vécu de la fin
du 19e siècle jusqu'au milieu du xxème
siècle
et déjà à son époque rené guénon observe
que le monde est en crise
plus exactement que le monde occidental
est en crise
crise économique avec cette crise
majeure qu'est le krach boursier de 1929
la plus grande dépression économique
qu'ait connue le 20e siècle
crise politique et militaire
rené guénon a vécu de près la première
guerre mondiale l'une des plus
sanglantes et traumatisante nous ayons
jamais connue
crise écologique
ça peut nous sembler surprenant mais dès
guénon parle du désastre écologique dont
se rend coupable l'occident à travers la
pollution liée à l' hyper
industrialisation
crise de l'éducation de la famille des
valeurs bref on croit parler notre
époque
il ne manque plus que la crise sanitaire
pour compléter le tableau
donc ce qui caractérise la modernité
pour rené guénon c'est la multiplication
et l'intensification des crises
qui selon lui participe tout d'une seule
et même crise globale qui est la crise
de la modernité
alors il faut tout de suite précisé que
quand on parle de crise on parle en fait
de deux choses
et il faut avoir à l'esprit ces deux
choses pour comprendre ce que veut me
dire rené guénon
on parle premièrement d'un moment
critique
crise critique c'est la même racine
pour le dire simplement on parle d'une
catastrophe
d'un dérèglement
d'un bouleversement voire d'un
effondrement
mais on parle aussi deuxièmement d'une
refondation
forme
autrement dit une crise ce n'est pas que
négatif
c'est une négatif qui débouche sur du
positif
alors on pourrait dire oui d'accord
c'est bien gentil mais rien n'est jamais
purement négatif
donc oui forcément si tout s'effondre
ensuite ça ne pourra que repartir
quand tout va mal
peut qu'aller mieux
oui c'est ça l'idée mais est ce que ça
veut dire au delà des mots c'est que la
crise est une phase transitionnelle
une crise indique le passage d'un état à
un autre
dans le langage courant on parle de
crise d'adolescence
le moment où l'enfant entame sa mue
samuel c'est à dire sa mutation ça
transforme a sion
on parle de crise de la quarantaine
ce mot on a l'impression que notre vie
stagne
qui nous pousse à tout envoyer valser
à revivre une dernière fois le frisson
de la jeunesse
pour entrer plus sereinement dans l'âge
de la maturité
donc les crises sont utiles
elles sont non seulement utiles mais
elles sont même nécessaires
nécessaire au sens d' inévitables
au sens donnons contournable
donc la crise du monde moderne c'est la
crise que l'occident traverse
actuellement qui se manifeste par toute
une série de crises dans tous les
domaines de l'existence
et que nous ne pourrons pas empêcher
parce qu'elle a un caractère de
nécessité
la crise on n'évitera pas
on n'y échappera pas
on ne pourra que la surmonter
et pour la surmonter il faudra
l'affronter
donc vous l'aurez compris rené guénon
s'est pas vraiment l'optimisme
mais en même temps si vous avez bien
suivi ce qui a été dit précédemment vous
aurez retenu que la crise
c'est aussi une condition pour des
lendemains meilleurs
c'est là où il faut aborder la
métaphysique kényane
en tout cas la métaphysique donc et non
se réclame
puisque guénon le dit lui même il n'a
pas créé une métaphysique
il a hérité d'une métaphysique que les
occidentaux modernes ont oublié
cette métaphysique c'est la métaphysique
des cycles cosmique
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire la
métaphysique des cyclos cosmique
à notre époque on est 10 les cycles
cosmique d'un point de vue si on fyk
essentiellement d'un point de vue
astronomique
nous savons par exemple qu'il existe des
cycles astronomique régulier
la révolution des planètes autour de
leur astre la rotation des galaxies
la précession des équinoxes
bref l'univers obéit à des cycles
et ses cycles s'inscrivent dans une
temporalité
sont même ce qui définit notre
un non ce n'est pas une durée définie
arbitrairement
ce n'est pas l'homme qui a inventé
l'année
un nom c'est le temps que met la terre à
faire un tour complet autour du soleil
d'où le lien étymologique entre année et
anneaux
l'idée de cercle
donc l'univers obéit à des cycles
bien ce que nous dit gay non est ce que
nous disent les doctrines métaphysique
de la tradition
c'est que l'humanité aussi obéit à des
cycles
que la mentalité et la manière d'être
des êtres humains obéissent également à
ces cycles
et que donc les événements qui se
produisent sur terre doivent d'abord
être compris comme des indicateurs de
notre position dans le cycle
est qu'actuellement nous sommes à la fin
d'un cycle
la fin du monde dont parle guénon
fin d'un cycle cosmique dont nous sommes
partie prenante
et auquel succédera un nouveau cycle et
ainsi de suite indéfiniment
donc vous voyez que pour gay non
contrairement à ce que pensent les
modernes
nous sommes finalement peu de choses
jeudi contre moins ce que pensent les
modernes parce que pour guénon l'homme
moderne se caractérise par son
égocentrisme
par sa haute conception de lui même
le péché de l'homme moderne selon guénon
c'est d'avoir oublié que son existence
s'inscrivait dans un cycle et dans un
devenir infiniment supérieur à lui
le devenir universel
et que ce devenir universel s'impose à
nous
l'erreur de moderne c'est d'avoir cru
qu'ils étaient capable de dompter
l'univers
or pour gay non c'est peine perdue
je cite souvent cette phrase de
descartes qui illustre parfaitement le
projet des modernes
se rendre comme maître et possesseur de
la nature
autrement dit faire de la nature et
nature en grec ça se disait phusis le
monde physique faire de la nature notre
propriété
c'est très prétentieux
l'humanisme c'est cette période de
l'histoire occidentale moderne pendant
laquelle les européens ont cherché à
conquérir la nature
à la conquérir pour la mettre au service
de l'homme
d'ailleurs l'humanisme s'inscrit dans
une période qu'on appelle la renaissance
la renaissance le fait de naître à
nouveau
qui peut naître à nouveau
si ce n'est dieu lui-même
la figure du christ ressuscité
donc il y a dans l'humanisme de la
renaissance il y a dans ce projet de
conquête de la nature une aspiration à
la divinisation de l'homme
une aspiration à remplacer l'absolu
divin par un absolu humain
et ça pour gay non c'est un signe de la
fin des temps
parce que c'est un signe que nous avons
oublié que des principes supérieurs nous
régissent
donc pour en revenir à nos cycles
cosmique guen on explique que l'humanité
a connu quatre grandes périodes 4 h
qu'on appelle dans la spiritualité
hindoue des youga je ne rentre pas dans
les détails je vous invite à vous
renseigner sur la cyclo logis hindoue si
ça vous intéresse d'approfondir
et il se trouve que ces quatre âges on
les retrouve aussi bien chez les pères
ce que chez les grecs et chez les
romains
à savoir l'âge d'or le satio yoga
l'âge d'argent le traita yoga
l'âge de 11 le doigt par ayew gars
et enfin l'âge de fer
le kali yuga
le kali yuga étant l'âge sombre
l'âge des ténèbres
et comme vous l'aurez compris nous nous
trouvons actuellement dans l'ère du kali
yuga
et même dans la ce terminal du kali yuga
je du désordre
et du rejet des principes supérieurs
et pour ceux qui aiment les maths noter
que la durée de chaque cube a décroît en
suivant une progression arithmétique
si on divise un mayuka en 10 portions
égales
le mailloux gailleton la totalité des
yogas
l'âge d'or dure quatre portions l'âge
d'argent trois portions
l'âge de bronze deux portions et l'âge
de faire une portion
4 3 2 1 ça rappelle le compte à rebours
mais ça surtout le tetraktys de
pythagore
le nombre de triangulaires
un symbole mystique bien connue des
initiés
et donc à la fin du kali yuga
l'humanité connaîtra l'apocalypse et
n'oublions pas qu'apocalypse en grec ça
signifie révélations
après quoi un nouveau maillot gars
s'enclenchera
s'ouvrira sur un nouvel âge d'or
pour redescendre lentement jusqu'au kali
yuga suivant
maintenant on va se pencher un peu sur
ce que dit rené guénon au début de la
crise du monde moderne son livre phare
publié en 1927
rené guénon nous dit que nous sommes
arrivés à la fin du dogme du progrès est
ce que ça veut dire
veut dire que nous avons une vision
ascensionnel de l'histoire
une vision ascensionnel ça veut dire
qu'on voit l'histoire humaine comme une
marche vers l'amélioration
amélioration de nos conditions
d'existence
amélioration des savoirs
des relations humaines
et c'est vrai que si on nous proposait
de vivre au moyen âge ou dans
l'antiquité
sans électricité sans téléphone
sans internet
non très nombreux à refuser
et ce 1 2 d'amande nos conditions
d'existence actuelle
parce que pour nous le passé est
forcément dépassé
le passé est forcément moins enviable
que le présent où le futur
c'est ça la traduction concrète de notre
conception du progrès
l'idée qu'aujourd'hui est meilleure
qu'hier
lorsque nous dit guen on sait que c'est
seulement sur le plan matériel qu'il ya
un progrès
oui louis xiv ne roulait pas en bm
je césar ne connaissait pas youtube
mais ces avantages de la modernité n'en
sont que pour ceux qui les possèdent
déjà
les gens du moyen âge ne souffrait pas
de ne pas avoir internet
les gens de l'antiquité ne souffrait pas
de ne pas avoir l'électricité
ces besoins sont apparus en même temps
que sont apparus les moyens de les
satisfaire
donc il n'y avait pas de manque
il n'y avait pas de frustration de ne
pas vivre dans la modernité
c'est logique
de même qu'aujourd'hui nous ne souffrons
pas du manque d objets qui n'ont pas
encore été inventé
voilà pourquoi guénon refuse d'appeler
progrès ce qui n'est en réalité qu'une
création de besoins
une création de besoins artificiels
qu'ils nous donnent l'illusion du
bonheur mais qui ne fait en réalité que
creuser davantage le puits de nos désirs
même chose relations humaines
les relations se sont certes pas s'y
fier mais ce sont l améliorer
sommes nous réellement plus solidaire
plus disponibles plus conviviaux
très n'est moins sûr
il se pourrait que ce que nous appelons
progrès soit en fait le progrès de
l'individualisme
le progrès de la solitude
de la misère affective
de là c'
est que les progrès de la technologie
progrès matériel donc et eu pour effet
de précipiter cet individualisme
de le renforcer
des écouteurs dans les oreilles
un écran devant les yeux et nous voilà
seul au monde
alors bien sûr qu'il y a des avantages à
la modernité
le nier serait malhonnête
mais la question est de savoir
est ce que l'humanité il y à gagner en
termes de bonheur
que les progrès matériel peuvent
raisonnablement constituer une finalité
en soi
pour le dire simplement
n'avons nous pas été victime
songes du progrès
c'est ce que pense rené guénon mais en
même temps guénon pense que ce mensonge
comment ça se remarque et
que ce mensonge commence à devenir
visibles
et rappelez-vous ce qu'on a dit tout à
l'heure on a dit que l'apocalypse
c'était la révélation
comme on révèle un mensonge
la crise du monde moderne c'est donc à
la fois le point culminant de ce
mensonge du progrès en même temps que le
moment de la prise de conscience de ce
mensonge
parce qu'il faut que les choses
atteignent leur point culminant pour
pouvoir être constaté par tous
donc la crise du monde moderne a bien
une issue positive
qui est la prise de conscience du
caractère mensonger du concept de
progrès prise de conscience qui
débouchera à l'issue duquel il houga sur
une refondation et une rénovation
donc pour en finir sur la notion de
progrès on pourrait dire que les
modernes ont appelé progrès ce qui en
fait devrait s'appeler développement
développer c'est étendre ses faire
croître
or comment dont l'indicateur de
prospérité économique des sociétés
modernes
vous l'avez deviné
la croissance
la modernité c'est cette époque à
laquelle on identifie l'amélioration à
l'augmentation
qu à laquelle on identifie la qualité à
la quantité
à laquelle on remplace la qualité par la
quantité
pour rené guénon notre époque est celle
du règne de la quantité
alors ici on pourrait avoir une vision
un peu réductrice de ce que nous dit gay
non
on pourrait dire par exemple ou que
biais non inaugure ce qu'on appellera
plus tard la critique de la société de
consommation
alors c'est pas faux mais ça va plus
loin
le règne de la quantité ce n'est pas
simplement le désir d'accumuler des
biens matériels
et pour le comprendre
maintenant expliquer ce qu'il se produit
selon la tradition
au cours d'un cycle cosmique
précisons d'ailleurs que quand on parle
de tradition ici on ne parle pas les
coutumes
et on ne parle pas non plus du
conservatisme
la tradition des noms parlent de
tradition primordiale avec un t
majuscule
c'est l'idée qu'il existerait une
spiritualité commune à tous les anciens
peuples et que cette tradition se
traduirait dans des formes culturelles
particulière
par exemple pour guénon la tradition
primordiale inclut aussi bien
l'hindouisme le bouddhisme
le taoïsme
aussi le christianisme et l'islam
dans leur version et ésotérique
et non considère qu'il ya une unité
profonde de toutes les doctrines
métaphysique traditionnelle et que leurs
différences ne sont que des différences
de forme lié au fait que chaque peuple
est spécifique et qu'il faut donc un
langage spécifique à chaque peuple
donc est ce qu'il se produit au cours
d'un cycle cosmique il se produit un
éloignement progressif du principe
spirituel
bon mais est ce que ça nous éclaire
bah oui ça nous éclaire
parce que ça veut dire que l'histoire de
l'humanité c'est l'histoire de la
matérialisation du monde
c'est l'histoire de la descente de
l'humanité dans la matière
dans les ténèbres de la matière
pour rené guénon un cycle cosmique se
caractérise par la chute du pôle
essentiel
vers le pôle substantielle
autrement dit du pôle spirituel
vers le pôle matériel
alors on va essayer de représenter sa
part une image
il m'a et une boule de lumière
cette boule de lumière c'est l'origine
du monde
l'origine spirituel du monde
maintenant
imaginez qu'une parcelle de lumière soit
éjecté de cette boule
et qu'elle tombe dans l'est profondeur
plus la parcelle de lumière tombe plus
elle s'éloigne de la source mais
également
plus elle perd en intensité lumineuse
plus elle or si
et sous les fêtes gravité la parcelle de
lumière accélère dans sa chute
et plus elle accélère plus elle se
refroidit
et en se refroidissant
elle se solidifie
elle devient matière
cette image illustre notre éloignement
progressif du principe spirituel
la boule de lumière c'est le principe
spirituel
d'origine divine
c'est l'âge d'or
l'unité
l'unité des hommes avec dieu et avec la
nature
avec la faune et la flore
l'éjection de la parcelle de lumière
c'est la séparation initial
l'entrée dans la dualité
c'est l'expulsion d'adam et eve
la domestication des animaux
et l'invention
thür
c'est l'âge d'argent
la chute de la part lumière c'est la
matérialisation
la création
la métallurgie
metallurgicales m de conquérir la nature
et de faire la guerre
c'est l'âge de bronze
arrive l'extinction de la parcelle de
lumière
la dissolution
l'âge de fer
le kali yuga qui met un terme au cycle
plus l'humanité
avance ton
plus elle s'éloigne du sip spirituelle
plus elle nie le principe spirituel
pour faire de la matière son unique
préoccupation
son unique mode d'être
remarquée comme nous sommes passés au
fil des âges d'une conception
métaphysique du monde a une conception
physique du monde
une conception spiritualiste du monde a
une conception matérialiste du monde
il ne s'agit pas de dire que c'est bien
ou mal
il s'agit d'observer l'évolution
la mentalité humaine
les cosmologies antique était des
cosmogonies
c'est à dire qu'on racontait la
naissance de l'univers à partir d'un
principe créateur lui même non matériel
la cause du monde matériel n'était pas
matériel
elle ne pouvait être que supra matériel
parce que dans le cas contraire cette
cause matérielle aurait elle-même une
cause qui la précède
rien de secret dans le monde matériel
tout n'est qu'argent en semant et ré
agencement
de la mythologie babylonienne
la genèse biblique il y avait toujours
un principe supra matériel à l'origine
de l'univers
un principe supra matériel dont
l'univers matériel n'était qu'une
émanation dégradé
or aujourd'hui lorsqu'on parle de
l'origine de l'univers
on parle pas d'un principe suprême
matériel
on parle du big bang
on parle de ce qu'il y avait avant le
big bang
du vide quantique
un vide pas totale vide
on est donc en recherche d'un principe
matériel à l'origine de l'univers
et d'ailleurs quand les physiciens parle
d'univers il parle de la matière qui
constituent l'univers
des planètes des galaxies de ce qu'on
appelle l'univers observable
donc il ya bien une épistémologie
matérialiste dans la science moderne
en physique comme en médecine
aujourd'hui on s'occupe de corps
donc demain hier
donc quand les modernes pense le monde
il le pense toujours sous l'ongle de la
matière
et ça rené guénon le met évidemment en
lien avec ce qu'il appelle le règne de
la quantité
pourquoi
que la quantité c'est ce qui est
mesurable
un corps se mesure
sa longueur sa largeur
sa masse
voilà pourquoi les mathématiques ou un
rôle central dans l'étude du monde
physique
d'ailleurs guénon fait remarquer qu'il
ya une parenté étymologique entre le mot
latin mais thierry qui signifie mesurer
et materia qui signifie matière
donc la matière c'est le mesurable c'est
à dire le quantifiable
mais la contrepartie c'est que tout ce
qui n'est pas quantifiable et chap à la
science moderne
un sentiment n'est pas quantifiable
une idée n'est pas quantifiable
une intention n'est pas quantifiable
or le matérialisme moderne a besoin que
tout soit quantifiable
quitte à rejeter ce qui ne l'est pas
dans les compos
mentalité moderne il y a donc le
matérialisme et ce n'est pas tout il ya
aussi et vous allez voir que c'est lié
le rationalisme
le rationalisme qu'est ce que c'est
c'est le fait considérer que seule la
raison permet d'accéder à des
connaissances fiables
le rationalisme c'est la prééminence de
l'intellect
alors on trouve déjà des traces de
rationalisme dans l'antiquité avec
platon
platon le défenseur du logos
défenseurs de la pensée rationnelle et
logique
mais platon considéré malgré tout que
l'intuition était un mode de
connaissance supérieure à la raison
l'intuition c'est la saisie immédiate
des essences
c'est donc le stade supérieur de la
raison
spinoza aussi croyez dans la puissance
de l'intuition
et chez spinoza aussi 28 son n'était pas
la négation de la raison mais le
dépassement de la raison
c'est au xviiie siècle avec emmanuel
kant que l'intuition allait être battu
en brèche
parce que pour quand l'intuition ne peut
porter que sur des objets sensibles
pas sur des objets intellectuelle
en clair quand tu pensais qu'il n'y
avait pas de mode de connaissance
supérieure à la raison est que la raison
était fondamentalement limité
l'entendement humain est limité
il ya des septe qui dépasse
littéralement l'entendement
comme le concept de dieu
pour quand il est impossible de
démontrer rationnellement l'existence de
dieu
parce que dieu se situe au delà des
frontières de la raison
et donc c'est avec quand qu'on entre
dans l'ère du rationalisme moderne
c'est-à-dire dans l'ère de la limitation
de la connaissance
et d'ailleurs vous remarquerez qu
aujourd'hui quand on dit qu'on sait
quelque chose par intuition on nous
regarde bizarrement
parce que d'un point de vue moderne
savoir par intuition ça veut dire
voir sans savoir pourquoi
dans la modernité l'intuition n'est pas
considéré comme un mode de connaissance
fiable
ce qui est considéré comme un mode de
connaissance fiable c'est la raison
c'est cette partie de l'esprit humain
qui décomposent qui disent aussi
qu'ils mesurent
elle encore l'étymologie nous renseigne
parce que qu'elle et l'étymologie du mot
raison
l'étymologie du mot raison ces ratios
qui a donné rationnelle
et raciaux ça veut dire calcul
c'est d'ailleurs qu'on retrouve en
mathématiques un ratio c'est un rapport
entre deux nombres
raison fonctionne sur ce principe de
mise en rapport
la raison quantifie elle additionne elle
soustrait elle divise
c'est le principe de chon ce qu'on
appelle le syllogisme
une opération logique
sauf que là encore nos digues et non
on réduit le champ de la connaissance
parce que la raison reste sourde à
certaines vérités qui ne sont pas de
l'ordre du raisonnement logique
il y a des choses que l'on sait sans
pouvoir expliquer pourquoi ni comment on
les sait
d'ailleurs si vous parlez avec des
mathématiciens vous découvrirez que
certains d'entre eux parviennent à
résoudre les équations de manière
intuitive
c'est à dire qu'il voit le résultat
avant de voir la démonstration qui
conduit à ce résultat
c'est sa nature sion
la cuisson vrai
donc pour
l'isthme le rationalisme c'est
l'application du règne de la quantité au
domaine de la connaissance
la raison quantifie pour connaître elle
sépare et dissociées
mais elle
sentent quand il s'agit de rassembler
quand il s'agit de synthétiser
la raison voit les différences avant de
voir les points communs
et donc pour guénon une connaissance
uniquement fondé sur la raison ne peut
être qu'une connaissance atrophiée
une connaissance amputés
et c'est là qu'on en a le troisième
pilier de la mentalité moderne
après le matérialisme et le rationalisme
à savoir
l'individualisme
l'individu son c'est la conséquence
logique est inéluctable du matérialisme
et du rationalisme
pourquoi parce que le matérialisme et le
rationalisme
couple individus de toute forme de
transcendance
le matérialisme et le rationalisme
nie l'existence de tout principe
supérieur
et donc en l'absence de principes
supérieurs
l'individu est privé de tout moyen
d'élévation
il devient son seul et unique
référentiel
que peut bien signifier s'élever s'il
n'ya rien au dessus de nous
à quoi bon
formé à des principes
si ces principes nous engagent que ceux
qui y croient
c'est une p deux temps
si la modernité est bel et bien la phase
d'éloignement ultime du principe
spirituel
c'est dans la mesure où la modernité a
rendu absurde l'idée de se conformer à
des principes suprin individuel
et là encore on retrouve le règne de la
quantité
parce que qu'est-ce qui compte quand
aucun principe supérieur ne guident
notre existence
la maximisation du plaisir
l'oubli de soi dans la pure sensation
la raison me dis que rien ne m
accessible au delà du monde de la
matière
donc je ne suis qu'un corps
et si je suis qu'un corps je doit jouir
de mon existence terrestre
et donc ce que nous dit rené guénon
c'est que la modernité c'est l'ère de
l'oubli de l'être dans l'agir
on agit pour ne pas voire à être
on agit pour s'agiter
parce que la gîte sion mais notre corps
en mouvement parce que l'agitation
rempli notre corps de sensations
et remplissant notre corps de sensations
agitation rend le spirituel superflu
le call you go c'est là matin alisation
de l'homme c'est l'agitation et
l'accélération comme principe
d'existence
et c'est à terme la dissolution de
l'être
je cite
c'est bien là en effet le caractère le
plus visible de l'époque moderne
besoin d'agitation incessantes de
changements continuels de vitesse sans
cesse croissante comme celle avec
laquelle se déroulent les événements
eux-mêmes c'est la dispersion dans la
multiplicité et dans une multiplicité
qui n'est plus unifiée par la conscience
d'aucun principe supérieur
c'est dans la vie courante comme dans
les conceptions scientifique l'analyse
poussée à l'extrême le morcellement
indéfini une véritable désagrégation de
l'activité humaine dans tous les ordres
ou elle peut encore s'exercer
et de là l'inaptitude à la synthèse
l'impossibilité de toute concentration
si frappante aux yeux des orientaux ce
sont les conséquences naturel et
inévitable d'une matérialisation de plus
en plus accentuée car la matière est
essentiellement multiplicité division et
c'est pourquoi disons le en passant tout
ce qui est en procès de ne peut
engendrer que des luttes et des conflits
de toutes sortes entre les peuples comme
entre les individus plus on s'enfonce
dans la matière plus les éléments de
division et d'opposition s'accentuer
s'amplifie à versements plomb s'élève
vers la spiritualité pur plus on
s'approche de l'unité qui ne peut être
pleinement réalisées que par la
conscience des principes universels ce
qui est le plus étrange c'est que le
mouvement et le changement sont
véritablement recherché pour eux mêmes
et non en vue d'un but quelconque
auxquels ils peuvent conduire et se
faire résulte directement de
l'absorption de toutes les facultés
humaines par l'action extérieure dont
nous signalions tout à l'heure le
caractère momentanée c'est encore la
dispersion envisagé sous un autre aspect
et un stade plus accentué ses
pourrait-on dire comme une tendance à
l'instantanéité ayant pour limite un
état de pure déséquilibre qui s'ils
pouvaient être atteints coïnciderait
avec la dissolution finale de ce monde
et c'est encore un des signes les plus
nettes de la dernière période du kali
yuga
ce rapport aussi la même chose se
produit dans l'ordre scientifique c'est
la recherche pour la recherche beaucoup
plus encore que pour les résultats
partiels et fragmentaire auquel elle
aboutit c'est la succession de plus en
plus rapide de théorie et d'hypothèses
sans fondement qui à peine édifié
s'écroule pour être remplacés par
d'autres qui dureront moins encore
véritable chaos au milieu duquel il
serait vain de chercher quelques
éléments définitivement acquis si ce
n'est une monstrueuse accumulation de
faits et de détail qui ne peuvent rien
prouver ni rien signifié nous parlons
ici bien entendu de ce qui concerne le
point de vue spéculatif dans la mesure
où il subsiste encore pour ce qui est
des applications pratiques il est au
contraire des résultats incontestables
et cela se comprend sans peine puisque
ces applications se rapporte
immédiatement au domaine matériel et que
ce domaine est précisément le seul où
l'homme moderne puisse se vanter d'une
réelle supériorité il faut donc
s'attendre à ce que les découvertes ou
plutôt les inventions mécanique et
industriel ait encore en se développant
et en se multipliant de plus en plus
vital aussi jusqu'à la fin de l'âge
actuel et qui sait si avec les dangers
de destruction qu'elle porte en elle
même elle ne serons pas un des
principaux agents de l'ultime
catastrophe si les choses en viennent à
un tel point que celle-ci ne puisse être
évitée
face à la crise que traverse le monde
moderne
coût s'interroge
beaucoup s'inquiètent
comment éviter la catastrophe
comment éviter l'apocalypse
est elle seulement évitables
que pas fait quelques êtres humains face
aux lois cosmiques
la fin du progrès on
partout des retour à la tradition
11 sans que la modernité est à bout de
souffle
qu'elle ne tient plus ses promesses
qu'elle ne rend pas les gens heureux
et donc on se replie dans les choses
solides du passé
le retour du religieux est un des effets
études modernes
en fin de compte le retour du religieux
pur produit de la modernité
une réaction
une réaction de défense
de défense
monde qui ne comble pas notre besoin de
sens
autres besoins lane au delà du matériel
notre besoin de spiritualité
la modernité a fait croire à l'homme
qui n'était qu'un corps doté d'une
raison
la modernité a fait croire à l'homme
que la spiritualité
était une chose du passé
chose dont il pourrait se passer
tant il est vrai que nous serions trop
évolué
reportée du crédit à la spiritualité
c'est au nom du progrès qu'on a amputé
l'être humain
on spirituel
et aujourd'hui on s'étonne que l'homme
moderne
âgés entre tourments et ressentiments
entre dépression et hystérie
entre addiction
et inertie
privé un être humain de ce
c'est comme privés une fleur de lumière
alors s'il ya là
que nous survivions à la modernité
et qu'il nous faille bâtir
le monde nouveau
ce ne sera pas en combattant
l'inéluctable
mais en le fécondant
de notre lumière
je vous remercie
[Musique]